Відпочинок і дозвілля надзвичайно важливі для німців.
Принаймні так каже третина опитаних.
Як німці знімають стрес, я спостерігав упродовж усього літа.
Так би мовити, працював відпочиваючи.
Друзі, всім привіт!  Я зараз перебуваю
у центральному парку Бонна - Райнауе.
Тут багато ось таких спеціалізованих місць для грилю.
Обов'язкові атрибути грилю по-німецьки – це сосиски і пиво.
Проте це не означає, що вегетаріанці під час грилю на природі
залишаться голодними чи змушені обмежуватися овочами.
У німецьких супермаркетах можна придбати
і вегетаріанські сосиски  для смаження на грилі.
Щоправда, ціни на них поки ще трохи кусаються:
якщо звичайні ковбаски зі свинини коштують близько 4 євро за кілограм,
то вегетаріанський варіант у 2,5 рази дорожчий
– 10 євро.
Друзі, ну а що ж за вільний час без приватних вечірок?
Сьогодні я не в Іспанії, не в Італії.
Подивіться, ось так, наче як на Середземномор'ї,
виглядає подвір'я боннського архітектора Рудольфа Гюрта,
і сьогодні він запросив на свою вечірку.
У Рудольфа на подвір'ї газовий гриль.
На ньому готувати зручніше і швидше, ніж на вугіллі у парку.
Затяті прихильники грилю на вугіллі, правда, кажуть,
що без димку не так смачно. Господар смажить для гостей
свої фірмові сосиски, які купує
у знайомого фермера з сусіднього містечка.
Я вам представляю найсмачнішу сосиску.
О Боже, так прекрасно виглядає!
Господар з гордістю розповідає про своє хобі,
показує сад та анонсує наступну гриль-вечірку
з власноруч вирощеними помідорами.
Для гостей-вегетаріанців тим часом окремо смажаться три різновиди сиру.
Не обійшлося і без традиційного для німецького застілля картопляного салату.
На десерт гості підготували для Рудольфа сюрприз –
ромову бабку з Києва.
О, українська випічка!
У Німеччині сильні традиції споживання пива.
Однак у Рейнському регіоні вино люблять не менше.
Напівсухе пасує як до м᾽яса, так і до десерту.
На здоров᾽я!
І на дозвіллі  архітектор і скульптор Рудольф Гюрт
не забуває про свою роботу. Адже гості завжди
охоче заглядають до майстерні засновника напряму стротопластика -
це унікальна технологія тривимірного живопису.
Від одного з гостей архітектора - доктора філософських наук
Леона Цвасмана отримую запрошення
на мистецьку вечірку у центрі Бонна.
Ну що ж, подивимося, як відпочиває німецька  богема.
Друзі, подивіться, вдень тут пральня, а ввечері збирається мистецька тусовка.
Простір поміж пральними машинками після 19:00
перетворюється на концертну залу.
Поети та музиканти виступають, художники малюють, бармени наливають.
Автор концепції вечірок "Кунстфло" Леон Цвасман
називає такий симбіоз спілкування і творчості - соціальним мистецтвом.
"Кунстфло" – це такий збірний витвір мистецтва,
коли творці різного плану творять разом -
література, музиканти, живі виступи, танцювальні перфоманси.
І так  вже 10 років. Це формат «ф᾽южн».
На "Кунтсфло" завжди запрошують також і митців-імігрантів
або закордонних виконавців, бо, за задумом організатора,
це має бути суміш різних культур.
Щодо віку - теж жодних обмежень.
Я народилася у 1935 році
і ще застала концерти Луї Армстронга.
Мені завжди потрібна музика для моєї душі і тіла,
і тоді я танцюю. Буває, ставлю свою камеру у кутку
і показую молодим людям, як треба танцювати.
Вони танцюють отак або отак
або якщо у них довге волосся - отак.
А я показую, що можна і ось так танцювати.
Гриль-вечірки і мистецтво – переважно на вихідних,
а от у будні німці нерідко знімають стрес після роботи фізичною активністю.
Ще одним типовим різновидом зняття стресу для боннців
після робочого дня є пробіжка по рейнській набережній.
Близько третини німців своїм улюбленим спортом вважають біг.
Регулярно бігають понад п’ять мільйонів жителів ФРН.
Марафони проводяться з найрізноманітніших приводів.
Навіть на честь свята виноробів - збору врожаю винограду -
є забіг - Аратон. Переможець отримає
стільки вина, скільки важить сам.
Звичайно, який же ж вільний час у Німеччині без Вандерунгу –
прогулянок на природі.
Чи не найвідомішим німецьким любителем піших прогулянок
був Йоганн Вольфганг Гете.
Він навіть казав, що людина по-справжньому бувала лише там, де була пішки.
Через майже два з половиною століття його традицію
продовжують близько семи мільйонів німців.
Коли бачиш таку кількість охочих прогулятися лісом,
як отут на околицях Бонна, навіть не віриться,
згідно з останніми опитуваннями, улюбленим заняттям
94 відсотків німців на дозвіллі є перегляд телевізора.
Втім, може, і Гете в цифрову добу був би радше популярним відеоблогером.
А це вечірнє тренування плавців-любителів у спортивному клубі міста Бонн.
Голова клубу Юрґен Баро Піца – у минулому профі.
Він навіть готувався до участі в Олімпійських іграх 1980 року у Москві.
Однак через бойкот Олімпіади країнами Заходу
після введення радянських військ до Афганістану
так і не поборовся за олімпійські нагороди.
За словами Юрґена, плавання не втрачає своєї популярності у німців.
У ФРН близько 600 тисяч плавців
є активними членами спорт-клубів.
Звичайно, не всі прагнуть спортивних результатів -
багато людей роблять це для здоров'я.
Любителі у нас займають доріжки з першої до третьої протягом усього дня
– з 6 ранку до 10-ої вечора.
Зараз опів на десяту вечора - подивіться скільки людей у басейні!
До речі, багато німців ходять у басейн не лише, щоб тримати форму,
а й аби розслабитися і поспілкуватися з друзями.
Особливо за сприятливої погоди і просто неба.
Друзі, температура повітря у Бонні наближається до плюс 40-ка градусів за Цельсієм.
Ще одне улюблене місце відпочинку німців -
це фрайбади або відкриті басейни.
Лише у Бонні і його околицях п'ять таких басейнів.
Окрім класичного олімпійського басейну для плавання
у них завжди є гірки та водяні атракціони.
Стенд ап7. Спека у Європі цього року знову б'є рекорди.
Тож я з родиною вирішив врятуватися від неї
на прохолодних озерах Словенії.
Це найбільший кемпінг країни - Шобєц.
У пік сезону він може прийняти до трьох тисяч людей.
Кожен третій номер машини тут - німецький.
Тож давайте запитаємо німців -
чому вони обирають такий спосіб відпочинку.
Німці подорожують кемпінгами Європи  ось у таких автобудинках
або чіпляють до машини кемпери - житлові причепи.
Я познайомився з родиною Лункенгаймер, яка обрала
найдешевший варіант - подорож мікроавтобусом зі своїм наметом.
Доба у п'ятизірковому кемпінгу  їм обходиться у 50 євро.
Сюди входить і оплата за собачку - 4,20 євро на добу.
Лункенгаймери з німецької землі Рейнланд-Пфальц.
Зараз родина готує традиційний сніданок по-німецьки -
булочки, сир, ковбаса та кава.
Я відпочиваю у кемпінгах з 18-річного віку.
Для мене це передусім свобода. Вирватися з повсякдення.
Для родини це гарна можливість побути разом,
бо у будні ми недовго всі бачимося, коли у дітей закінчується школа.
Тут ми цілий день разом і можемо навіть посваритися.
Проведення часу тут, на відміну від готелю,
дозволяє мені бути напіводягненим під час сніданку,
і це нікого тут не турбує. Можу їсти, що хочу,
і, звичайно ж, тут переночувати значно дешевше, ніж в готелі.
Це справжній відпочинок. У мене з собою немає кухні.
Тільки найнеобхідніше. Я можу весь день читати,
гуляти або час від часу купатися в річці.
Геть від повсякденного стресу!
Ну що ж, друзі, а для усвідомлення масштабів цього кемпінгу
пропоную на нього подивитися з висоти пташиного польоту.
одойми, ліс – родина Лункенгаймерів
знайшла для себе ідеальні умови для повноцінного відпочинку.
До речі, Словенія - доволі популярний напрямок для німецьких туристів ще й тому,
що ціни тут нижчі порівняно, наприклад, з сусідньою Австрією.
Увечері у кемпінгу відбувається концерт,
і німецькі туристи знову почуваються, майже як удома.
Словенські альпійські пісні дуже схожі на німецькі.
Друзі, я також набрався нових сил, тож пишіть у коментарях,
що ще вам цікаво знати про німців,
їхній побут і традиції, і я обов'язково покажу це
у наступних серіях. Побачимось!